we obviously didn't get done last year  but the addition of Kevin was huge you  know that skill on the floor tonight was  so amazing between these two teams and  so to be able to go to Kevin every time  the game got tight you know along with  the other guys that we've got on this  team with staff from play and dream on  it's pretty lethal combination  basketball is a team sport you want to  play well for your teammates and y'all  just run it together man this was all  about you know it's not about  individuals it's not about your own  agendas it's about team and we preached  that from day one and we were the best  team in the league and feels good to be  a part of that we came through we  accomplished our goal that's always the  goal for us to try to win a championship  and you can't do that until you've done  it all and that's the fire that  continues to drive us